hi guys welcome back to my channel today
I'm going to talk about something that
is I think really relevant in language
learning and it is about how to reach
proficiency in a foreign language I get
asked this question quite a lot
Marseille and so I decided to make a
video about it and also to rise to
awesome articles that my friend Kevin
Morehouse and I wrote together so you
can see the first part if you click on
the link below this video relates to the
first part and it gives you a definition
of some terms and gives you the
framework within which we're going to
elaborate on some cool strategies on how
to reach proficiency now without further
ado I would like to tell you a little
bit about the concept of fluency and the
concept of proficiency now for me
fluency and once again I would like to
stress the fact that fluency is a term
that is difficult to define objectively
so I'm going to give my own definition
for me fluency means to be able to use
the language smoothly that is you're
able to talk to people you're able to
understand what people tell you but this
doesn't necessarily imply mastery of the
language it doesn't necessarily imply
that you can do everything perfectly
without mistakes or being able to read
books or talk perfectly at conferences
as we will see in a little bit so to
make a long story short for me fluency
is the capability of communicating so
talking and also understanding what is
being said to you and daily in a
database conversion while mastery is
something that is related more to with a
term proficiency actually proficiency is
a term that implies a higher level than
proficiency so bear with me with this
with this definition in general for me
being fluent apart from being able to
talk and understand in anything in sheer
terms of vocabulary means to know more
or less 5000 terms 5,000 words normally
the most common words while if you are
proficient you know more normally
then 10,000 words which allows you to as
you will seem a little bit to understand
more complex you know things and and
indulge in more complex activities let's
break it down a little bit so I really
like defining things more in detail
because I think it helps elaborate cool
and efficient strategies more you know
that in language learning we have 4
errors who have reading listening
speaking and writing for me a fluent
reader is a person who's able to read
generally short and simple texts but I
can also read newspapers can also read
books but struggle a little bit
especially with vocabulary and has to
look up some terms that he doesn't
normally know to give you an example I
think I consider myself a fluent speaker
of Russian I can do interviews I can
talk to people I went to Russia and I
interacted with everybody and still when
reading some more complicated books for
example I'm reading others specifically
and reading one book about work about
World War two and when Germans invaded
Russia I find it a little bit difficult
to to understand everything military
tactics etc on the other hand a somebody
who mastered Russian or who's proficient
in Russian let's say that he has at
least a c1 level in the common European
framework of languages he is able to
read any book and doesn't have to look
up a lot of words of course we still
have to look up words but not not very
not very often then in terms of
listening once again if you're a fluent
speaker of a language and I'm still
considering the example of Russian I can
talk to people I can understand what
people say I can even understand things
you know in simple movies but when it
comes to more complicated things or
people talking to each other around the
table or more complicated stuff like for
example lecture university that is more
difficult and they think that a c1 is a
more appropriate level to to understand
a comedy for example Russian comedy or a
lecture at a university etc for speaking
at the same thing you can
be affluent speakers can get your point
across while making mistakes and maybe
even having an accident but when you are
proficient in the language then you're
able to hold a lecture at University and
get your point across in an elegant way
that is do you have multiple you have
multiple possibilities you can opt for
one word or one sentence instead of
another so it's not like you have to
choose just one path and the simplest
path and as for writing that's the same
thing if you're a fluent writer you can
speak to use and sorry you can use an
app you can chat with your friends you
can write simple email or writing in an
elegant way well that's another cattle
fish as they say now the question that
you might be you might be wondering but
look okay this is this is all niacin
but how would you reach and see one
level from b2 well first of all I all
want to tell you that the reason why a
lot of people get stuck at this Beach
level is because they feel comfortable
with it when you reach a b2 well you can
do a bunch of things you can even live
in the country you can go to a bar and
talk to people interact and
conversations and multiple conversations
yes of course you might struggle a
little bit in some its certain regard
but yours you have started already
enjoying the language and so when you
tell yourself you know what I don't need
to do that and the second thing is
because people get caught in the
so-called if they get stuck in a triple
plateau they use this in the whisks you
can also use this term when you
literally hit a wall I got a lot of
messages saying for example Booga I got
stuck now I've been learning so much and
I've been making progress but then I got
stuck all of a sudden well the reason
why that happens is that imagine
learning a language like climbing a
mountain right so you start climbing the
mountain and then all of a sudden the
the wall or the slope becomes so steep
that you can't go up now the problem is
that if you want to reach c1
you basically have to change you have to
keep water you have to keep walking but
you have to change the way you walk how
you walk that is going to make the
difference and this is what we're going
to talk
in the next video and what you're going
to see in the next article where I'm
going to share five crucial strategies
on how to reach Siwon um if you like
this video if you haven't subscribed yet
please subscribe you're going to see a
lot of cool stuff this year and not only
on my youtube channel also if you
haven't subscribe to the blog go to the
blog subscribe we're going to send you a
bunch of interesting things so once
again thanks a bunch for listening to me
and I'm going to see you very soon in
the next video bye bye ciao